bonjour à tous sont nés au mwc à
barcelone il là j'ai en main le nouveau
téléphone de lg le lg les 30 messe
alors il ya quelques mois à l'ifa
j'avais pris en main déjà le lgv 30 ça
c'est le petit frère tué le gp30 les gv
et 30 s
alors ce qu'on va faire ce qu'on va
d'abord regarder un peu les
spécifications techniques de ce produit
parce qu'elle en vente et voir ensuite
quelles sont les différences par rapport
aux lgv 30
est-ce que ce téléphone vaut le coup oui
ou non on a un écran 6 pouces quad hd +
oled avec un ratio 18/9 de 1880 par 1440
pixels
côté processeur vous avez un stade
ragots 835 à l'intérieur si giga de ram
128 giga de stockage et vous pouvez
mettre une carte micro sd pour monter
jusqu'à de terreur pour de terrain sait
pas vraiment si vous n'avez l'utilité ce
que vous allez mettre en terme de photos
et vidéos de terrasser énorme mais en
tout cas si vous voulez vous pouvez le
faire
côté batterie vous avez une 3300
millions terreur à connecter qui sait de
l'usb tisser vous avez un doute ou ce
5.0 à l'intérieur il a une certification
ip68 résistante à l'eau et à la
poussière à l'arrière vous avez deux
caméras une caméra normale 16 mégapixels
avec une ouverture de f
1.6 et une caméra grand angle 13
mégapixels avec l'ouverture de f1 points
9 grand-angle ses 120 degrés c'est vrai
que c'est impressionnant ça use mais ça
permet effectivement d'avoir de beaux
rendu nos proches à l'avant vous avez
une seule caméra de 5 mégapixels avec
une ouverture de 2.2 qu'on ne cherchait
pas à voir beaucoup de luminosité
mais bon des petits selphy classique
sympa sans grande folie il est
disponible dans deux couleurs le gris
comme ça et aussi un coloris bleu
[Musique]
quelle est la différence entre le lg les
30 et le sg du 30 s
alors en fait la vraie différence se
fait au niveau du logiciel est aussi un
peu au niveau du matériel
vous avez si j'ai gadrat contre 4 gigas
de ram vous avez un peu plus de stockage
mais surtout au niveau software vous
avez une machine qui est boosté à
l'intelligence artificielle c'est à dire
reconnaissance de scène vous prenez en
photo un chien en peluche pour un chien
ça vous reconnais que c'est un chien jeu
des fleurs ça vous reconnais que ce sont
des fleurs que vraiment la couleur et la
luminosité pour avoir une image qui est
vraiment pas parfaite mais quasiment que
je reproche c'est effectivement un petit
peu trop saturation se trouve que
l'image est trop saturé c'est hyper
flatteur alors effectivement c'est joli
si vous partagez son et image hyper
clinquante mais malgré tout on reste un
petit peu loin de la réalité
peut-être qu'il va garder évolutions
logicielles en fonction des retours
mais sinon sur le principe la
reconnaissance de scène est plutôt pas
mal fichu entre point super intéressant
avec suel j'évite 30 s lorsque vous
prenez par exemple la photo a produit
vous voyez qui vous plaît que soit une
chaise une table ou quoi que ce soit
vous la prenez en photo avec le mode
achat sur amazon se bat vous le
reconnaître et vous proposer le produit
similaire au même produit acheté sur
amazon donc ça s'est vraiment bien parce
qu'on était une vraie compréhension de
l'objet
un scan vraiment du produit dont je vous
propose le même produit
autre point intéressant c'est la
recherche par image imaginez vous êtes
en voyage passe en plus amenés à
barcelone je vais aller je sais pas la
sagrada familia au parc guell je vais
prendre une photo ça va me proposer des
images similaires
ça permettra effectivement de savoir
quelle est la chose que j'ai pris en
photo alors sagrada familia c'est
partout mais on peut imaginer sur des
points touristiques tu sois pas
forcément écrit par tout ça c'est
intéressant
il ya un vrai sens derrière ça le seul
regret c'est qu'aujourd'hui ça ne marche
qu'avec pin terrestre pas à google
images c'est vraiment dommage parce que
effectivement quitté reste il ya
beaucoup de contenu mais il faudrait
l'enrichir avec d'autres banques d'image
d'autres bases de données ce sera encore
plus intéressant pareil pour l'achat
aujourd'hui c'est uniquement avec amazon
affectivement eva joly dans la zone elle
est monstrueuse et on peut très bien
imaginer d'avoir d'autres tyler ce
serait très intéressant aussi
autre point intéressant vous avez le
scan de qr qu ils vont s'en trouve un
petit peu partout voskanian qr code
ça vous ouvre les fonctionnalités
programmé dans le qr code bon sens
renvoie effectivement un peu ailleurs
mais c'est un sens de le mettre en vol
un petit peu la différence entre le lgv
30 et le g litre en presse c'est
vraiment l'intelligence artificielle on
voit que toute façon c'est une tendance
très très forte en 2018 l'accentuation
de l'intelligence artificielle
on l'a vu avec les honneurs view disque
sorti en début d'année on le voit avec
les produits de huawei on le voit on va
encore plus loin avec bixby 2.0 de chez
samsung avec apple avec siri qui a pu
enfin voilà l'intelligence artificielle
c'est vraiment un des défis majeurs une
position sur lequel il faut être en 2018
et là effectivement lg prend le tournant
avec son lgv 30 s est ce que c'est
encore la solution idéale
il ya encore des choses qui sont un peu
reid et le fait d'être que sur amazon
que sur pin terrestre est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui leur est avant tout
comprend faudra le voir à l'utilisation
d'ailleurs dit ma bouche certes vous
intéressait ce que vous avez déjà un gvt
et rang des produits de lg est ce que
vous comprenez est ce que vous trouvez
que c'est l'algérie 30s a vraiment un
intérêt marqué ma tout son commentaire
bien évidemment je vous invite à mener
cette jolie pub ça nous a donné parce
qu'on attendait toujours plus de
produits hi tech innovante de
smartphones beaucoup de chocs
merci d'abord regarder cette vidéo on va
continuer parce que là on est au bout by
the world congress à barcelone il ya
énormément de choses à voir et ça c'est
super cool merci ciao
[Musique]